I'm not really quick about an
announcement that Sony just made
regarding spider-man they have said that
they are they have a plan to start
releasing a new spider-man movie every
year they're also I already talked of a
number of spin-offs we've got confirmed
work being done on venom and a sinister
six movie so what it looks like Sony's
trying to do it looks like they're
trying to build something like Marvel's
Cinematic Universe but only with
spider-man you know this is just a much
smaller world than Marvel is though the
reason Marvel can get away with
releasing two films a year is that the
franchise's just feel completely
different fun on a fundamental level
Thor does not feel like Captain America
spider-man you know it's all confined to
New York and they've got a much more
limited staple of characters to pull
from it's just it is it gonna get old
too quick and honestly I'm still kind of
scratching my head over a sinister six
movie how is that gonna work who's your
hero because the sinister six certainly
aren't heroes but if somehow you got to
turn them into some kind of anti heroes
are you then not gonna be able to use
them as villains for future
spider-man installments that cuz if that
ends up being the case you've just blown
six villains that you can't use again
for spider-man to face off against I
just I'm questioning that they're just
doing too much and doing too much too
fast maybe they've got a plan for how
this is all gonna work but it feels like
they're just throwing everything against
the wall hoping it all sticks but you
know what this can't all stick and if
spider-man was happening in isolation I
would actually kind of welcome a
spider-man movie every year but we're
talking about a spider-man movie or
sparring right or spider-man related
movie every single year plus Marvel's
output plus Man of Steel 2 plus x-men
plus Fantastic Four's movie vordigan
guys you're gonna flood the market with
too many superheroes and the whole
thing's gonna come down you can't all be
throwing this much stuff we've managed
up to this point because there was
usually two years between any next
installment in any given singular
franchise you start cranking a movie a
year on a franchise and actually
if it works it may even be worse because
then fox is gonna try and do it with
x-men and next thing you know DC is
gonna try and do it with Justice League
movie and it's just it's you're gonna
overload the whole thing and everybody's
gonna get bored eventually even the fans
are gonna start going yeah Super Heroes
what else you got
I'd this makes me nervous I'm there's
still a certain amount of excitement but
mostly right now nerves
big nerves so what are your thoughts do
you think we need the spread of a movie
every year drop something in the
comments let's talk about it and until
next time this council is adjourned